spoken about quite a few things today
that i've never really spoken about
james smith the world's fastest growing
online personal trainer but he's much
more than that like a driving instructor
i should not exist in your life in six
months why is it so acceptable for
people to invest money into fitness
professionals and then still be there
three years later so if you do your job
well enough your client leaves
if people were truly happy i would have
been shut the hell up then and i
wouldn't have experienced so much growth
from pointing out the inadequacies i
don't like people that presents a
solution without education it breaks me
to think of the tens of thousands of
people who gave up on their ambitions
because they went the wrong way for
advice and when they fail the plan or
don't finish it they blame themselves
where the hell have you come to the
conclusion that you would not succeed
following your passion i just wish that
maybe earlier on someone had said to me
okay you're not doing well here but this
doesn't mean you're not intelligent
there is something else you could do
very well
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much james smith
the world's fastest growing online
personal trainer but he's much more than
that he's an author of three books his
third one's about to come out he's
unapologetic he is outspoken and he says
it how it is
and that's meant that he now reaches
millions of people online every single
week i had an expectation on james i've
seen him on social media i've seen the
types of things he says when he's on
telly
but the guy i met today
deeply self-aware
unbelievably humble
and so incredibly wise and because he's
so honest in straight talking i walk
away with some lessons that i genuinely
believe will stay with me for a lifetime
you are gonna love this one trust me
when i say that
without further ado i'm stephen bartlett
and this is the dire ceo i hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this to yourself
james you've listened to this podcast
before um so you probably know that i
tend to start in a similar place i tend
to ask my guests about their early years
but when i was reading about
comments you'd made about your early
years one of the things you said is it's
not not much very interesting happened
yeah i mean
it's one of those things where i was
like there's so many things to talk
about let's not go there
as a
young child in school
didn't have a huge amount of friends and
i think that primary and secondary
school if you had to pick five people
that are never going to accomplish
anything in life i would have been in
that that group of people
i was diagnosed with learning
difficulties which
kind of been disputed i remember jimmy
carr talking about
getting that laptop and it's true you
had to see an educational psychologist
and at the end they were like
james's reading and writing speed is
very quick we think he's just lazy
and
throughout school i was in the cloakroom
and they give you extra time in exams
which i didn't need because i was so
bored i'd be done the exam 20 minutes
before everyone else and just sat there
not through being intelligent but like i
can't be bothered with this
and a lot of behavioral issues at school
if i look back at that i almost feel
like my brain was only
functioning at 20
throughout the whole education system
probably up until college and dropping
out of university in my first year
and you were adopted yes this is a
open topic and i even before this
podcast i was like i wonder if any other
high achievers are adopted
found steve jobs jamie foxx
uh marilyn monroe was in the list
and i was trying to figure out if i
could
draw any
you know relations to other people that
have done it i've even read books where
someone on instagram is like oh if
you're adopted you should read this
because it resonated with me
and i bought these books and talks about
abandonment and senses of
you know unfulfillment i didn't really
relate with any of those topics so
i think that as far as
a kind of dream adoption story i ended
up in the smith family you know blonde
hair blue eyes
mum and dad still together now each
other's first girlfriend and boyfriend
so i was incredibly fortunate with that
having come all this way in your life
and learnt a ton from the books you've
written and i know that's such an
introspective process but all the people
you've spoken to all the dm's you must
get are there any sort of dots you've
connected now that
have made you realize that being adopted
was in any way consequential to who you
were to become
it's difficult i'm still discovering it
uh
you know with relationships i think it's
a very
interesting one i've had conversations
with other adopted people and they they
say to you like
you become very attached to people very
quickly because
you know
it's a very strange thing never seeing a
blood relative before so
you might look at your parents and other
people look at their parents and you
know uncle they see features i've never
had that and you never feel like your
parents aren't your parents because i'm
a strong believer there if you bring you
up
but then sometimes in relationships
maybe i'm a bit cold maybe i'm a bit too
intense i'm always judging that and over
analyzing it and people ask me as well
they're like oh do you think you're this
way because you're adopted and
suddenly you're overthinking a lot
you're like is it is it not is it
something that's a big part or a small
part and it's very difficult to get
answers for that
when you go through school and you go
through like early the early teen years
and then you've got people telling you
you've got a learning
issue and then they're giving you
special treatment and all these things
at that point in your life having like
bounced around a little bit and not
really fit anywhere in terms of the
system
do you think in hindsight you were
learning that you were like not good
enough
100
and i think that i definitely wore that
for the next four or five years but i
thought the only place i'm going to be
accepted is a
bottom position in a corporate gig 20k a
year i started off on 18
sales department i'm gonna have to cold
call people and kind of work my way up
slowly
so that's what i did for my early
twenties
worked in the sales department 18k basic
then jumped to another one for 20k basic
i thought i'll do this for five to ten
years get to a management role do that
for five to ten years maybe get near a
directorship role
and i think that's what a lot of people
who have failed the education system
think but like well that's what people
do oh i might try recruitment which i
also did for a year and everyone said oh
you learn good money but you hate it i'm
22. i'm like how can you earn good money
and hate it i did recruitment it was
good money and i hated it
so it was it's one of those things where
definitely i do feel that
if we paint people when we see people
get bad grades at school
we should you know have a more open
conversation about okay you're not doing
well like this what do you think you'd
be good at
and
i mean even in the last 10 years
don't play video games there's no future
in that now there is you know don't
spend all day on your computer there's
no future in that now there is
so
i just wish that maybe earlier on
someone had said to be okay you're not
doing well here but this doesn't mean
you're not intelligent
there is something else
in a lateral you know pathway that you
could do very well up what would you say
to someone and i imagine there's a lot
of people listening to this now who are
driving in their cars now in the
motorway because i see them upload the
podcast when they're like driving
they're on the treadmill on monday
morning etcetera
and they're in that job
where
but there's that voice inside them
that's saying you know what you could
have done more and you've got so much
more potential but they've believed the
narrative
they're like corporate just climb your
way up some [ __ ] ladder
i have two answers to that
the first so many people
are hitting quotas
working for someone else's goal so in
recruitment people go
i just don't think you know i'd be able
to accomplish much on my own i go okay
but you're doing something you don't
enjoy and you're exceeding at it you're
excelling at it you've hit quota for
three years and something you're not
passionate about
where the hell have you come to the
conclusion that you would not succeed
following your passion how have you come
to that conclusion that's
ridiculous
now the second thing is
although this has been disputed i'm a
big believer and i'm sure you will too
in income satiety that after you earn a
certain amount of money there's a
tapering off effect
and it's very difficult to to say that
because straight away people's defense
is well it's okay for you because you've
gone past that that curve i'm still on
the way up and i say to them
you're probably working your career for
another 10 years because you think in 10
years time you're going to have enough
money to eventually be happy with your
situation
what if that bet is wrong what if you've
just lost 10 years and you're not happy
what if
i think the two people there's two ways
of thinking
some people think it's an exponential
return where they'll go through misery
for long enough and then boom they're
just happy i said to them how do you
think millionaire ceos wake up out of
bed like oh my god
life is so good it's the exact same they
wake up same as you i can't wait to have
a cup of coffee
and then the other one
is more of a linear scale where they go
okay
3k this much happiness 40k this much 50k
this much
i say to them what if in 10 years time
you're wrong
10 years is a lot more than 10 years
between 30 and 40. 10 years a lot more
than 10 years between 20 and 30.
imagine always think in the back of your
mind that that bet is going to be wrong
and if you could fast forward to 10
years time and see that you made the
wrong bet
how would you feel now think about that
before you make a decision that's so
true you know i
linked up link up tv published a video
with me the day and the type they put
the title as like money won't make you
happy which is not what i said but i
understand why they're doing it we've
got to get them clicks and um i did see
i saw the comments that said very
similar thing it was like oh it's easy
for you to say i'm like well
it would take someone that's made a
million to tell you that a million isn't
it i couldn't have told you when i was
broke like so and also i have no
incentive to to like put you off
getting rich i'm just telling you i'm
letting you know that up here
my happiness didn't scale proportionate
to my wealth
to a point so as you say 75k per
household apparently it starts to
plateau just letting you know
i always say to people it's very
important they understand this
all wins feel the same
all wins extreme you don't get an uber
surcharge on dopamine the way our brain
chemistry works you know okay pleasure
serotonin dopamine you don't get a 1.7
surcharge because you're wealthy so you
know when you secure a deal at a
mid-level high level or you know stock
exchange level it's the same dopamine
response and it's one of those things
where people go oh my god okay yeah and
buying a car whether it's a lamborghini
or a brand new golf
people cannot comprehend that that win
feels the same and i love to tell them
i'm like no it exactly is
and when people set goals and i don't
like the conversation going into fitness
but
they say i want to lose 10 kg i'm like
lose 1kg damn it and then celebrate that
because that feeling of stepping on the
scale and accomplishing something is the
same at 1 kg as it is at 10. you've just
denied yourself a long way before you're
allowed to be happy which i think is
what human beings are really bad at we
won't let ourselves celebrate wins at
the level we choose not only do they
feel the same we get to determine where
those wins are
did you find that success wasn't what
you thought it would be well this is
interesting because and people don't
believe me when i say this i never
intended for this
i never had dreams of
being
what i would i would consider it wealthy
and people will watch this and they'll
go no no the other guy's wealthy and
i'll say no no on from a subjective
standpoint i've been able to buy my
friends and my family dinner without him
to check my bank account for like four
years
that's something that i didn't have for
the 28 before it that's wealthy right
and um
it it's one of those things i never
really wanted if i'm completely honest
my goal as a personal trainer was 10
clients three sessions a week pay me
well
i don't want 30 clients doing 30 hours i
want 10 that see me three times a week
i'll be in london or i'll be in sydney
if they skip a session it's 150 pounds
an hour they won't mind because they're
good high level clients
that was it that was the goal what
happened
i became
process orientated
probably
2015. where on social media
for the first time investments don't
really interest me that much and this is
another crazy thing people hate me about
the social media investment did
i will post
something useful every day here for
years 10 years i thought and in 10 years
time hey guys here's a book
jing make 20 grand whatever
and as i was posting into email
marketing i wrote email marketing emails
for 10 months before i made this out if
you had met me nine months in you would
have thought i was [ __ ] insane hey
james what are you doing i'm writing
emails to who
300 people what about my online pt
program how many have been buying it or
none so far
social media three years in what are you
doing i'm posting every day how much
money have you made none people have
gone you're [ __ ] mental
nowadays they go okay fair play but
then the the momentum that i wanted i
just wanted a life where i didn't have
to see clients they'd seek me i just
wanted a life where i could post about a
book and money would appear on my
account
and after doing that for three four
years
i feel like the table's hot and i enjoy
being at the hot table and rather than
looking at an exit strategy i've created
a life that i love where
send a marketing email
market my brand so i can get people to
email
manage my academy
you know promote books and write them
i have everything i need i'm i'm like on
a wave that just never seems to end and
that to me i mean carol dweck one of my
favorite authors becoming is better than
being i never wanted to be anything in
particular so there's no gold medal
depression at the end right remember
that from your pod that's that's not
there for me because i've never set an
everest peak i've never said that so
this wave that's moving for me i'm just
happy and do you know what
i've i joke around all the time i'm like
if this ends tomorrow what a ride you
know and i don't think enough people see
it that way where you know
i know you've had the pleasure of taking
friends on a private jet
i did that once and i was like wow if i
if i die tomorrow they'll be like rest
in peace though hopefully they'll cry he
took me on the jet
for one night and then i if this all
came crashing down i'd be happy with
that because i never set it you know
there are so many boxers who wanted to
be heavyweight world champion they never
made it they've got to go to the grave
with that i almost feel like there's a
element of being unbeatable when i never
set a precipice to reach yeah
i mean mo gouda which is one of my
favorite podcasts i've ever done here
talks a lot about that that you know
unhappiness is in essence when our
expectations of how life is supposed to
be going go unmet
and he's there they call him a happiness
expert genius on the topic and even
billionaires they have expectations of
their steak tasting like
japanese wagyu
perfection 10 out of 10. so if it comes
and it's a 9 out of 10 steak
they are often furious the [ __ ] is this
medium rare i said right whereas you
take that exact same steak you give it
to
you know someone else that's on 18k a
year they'll be like because their
expectations are lower and they're
they're all overall standards are low
they will be over the [ __ ] moon same
stake two different people with two
different sets of expectations it's
interesting as well where uh next time
you're at a table with people that are
very accomplished
i noticed the people that have
experienced the stake that much
they're so much more involved in
conversations because that's the only
thing that can interest them on that
night yeah they've had 10 and this is
something that petrifies me where
sometimes i feel like i want to be
successful but not too much yeah because
once you've eaten at every five-star
restaurant in london like you say your
standard's been set once you've dated 10
models standards have been set
and
i almost do feel sorry for sometimes the
bezos the bilzerians you know i think
wow i'm like
what what are you doing each day to
excite you and this is why
not to hijack the conversation but
brazilian jiu jitsu for me
is like
a nucleus of my focus my attention what
i care about on a daily basis because
nothing can really impact that and i
will never be able to get to a status
where
no matter no matter who i am what i do
or what i accomplish when i step on the
mats we get in belt order
for years at mile gym we all wipe down
the sweat after the mats like you know
black belts get our gears off when we do
it
and it's so important to me that i know
that for the rest of my life when i can
still train
i will never be too big for that
and i think that there are so many high
achievers that love that connection to
it
and
i feel sometimes with people that are
super successful they're not getting
beatings enough they're not for me i can
i remember
uh did a business to business event
i flexed when i was there i was like hey
guys i was wearing a gold rolex which i
actually just saw this morning and i was
there i was like hey you know
here's here's what it's like flying
first class we're in obesity oh you know
i was flexing on a business talk next
day went to compete lost in the first
round
you know turned up i was like wow it's
like thank you for that thank you my
weekend i would have been taking off as
far as you go if it wasn't for getting
beaten up on sunday do you know what so
so many people have told me about
brazilian jiu jitsu and the way they
speak about it isn't like it's a sport
or a martial art it's more like a
like a philosophy for life
almost it teaches you life lessons and
so many people have told me that in a
row that i thought you know i need to
give this a shot and i really enjoyed it
even though it was one a one-on-one
session and i was in indonesia
for two hours i was like i need to do
this more often you know like marketing
social media email marketing you are
going to be awful for the first six
months you are but if people persevere
through that and again i remember where
i learned a lot of my business now so i
was i was in victoria i was in a
doubletree hilton i was in a room with
200 personal trainers we all learnt the
same thing that day and i remember the
faces of the people in there and i never
saw them again i've never seen them on
socials i've never seen them on
instagram on tick tock anywhere like
that
and i think to myself we all learnt the
same thing just not all of us stuck with
it through the the
painful times where in email marketing
you spend six months you don't make
money in jiu jitsu you spend six months
you don't beat anyone you have to say to
yourself right i'm happy to endure this
because i know come the other side i can
reap the rewards
and
it's very difficult in this day and age
to say to someone let's do we're going
to get you to do something where you
physically
are going to be powerless for six months
it doesn't sell well that narrative but
then when you get when you get through
it if similar to people i i love the
email marketing analogy now so many
people in the new rich can send an email
and that's their day's work done because
they persevered they built the
relationship they managed to cultivate
an audience who are ready for it same
with jiu jitsu
if people just commit to it and like you
say when people talk about it you're
like this isn't a coincidence it
i drink less i party less
i
you know have now ambitions of teaching
my future kids i have ambitions of
teaching white belts i want to go back
to sydney i'll say to my gym hey
no one wants the fundamentals class no i
love them i'll have them same with pt
world i never wanted to train athletes i
like just
first time sharon
who is a housewife and she has to make
sure the kids are at school on time
teach her to deadlift i was like that's
what brings me pleasure and i think that
i'll really enjoy teaching the white
belts and so many people
they have so much that they are kind of
working for in life but nothing that's
such a slow gradual progression like a
martial art in the middle
you've highlighted there one of the
things that evidently made you
successful was that commitment to
consistency and like i mean you would
you would have seen it in your social
channels because every successful person
i've seen
and i speak to says the same thing first
couple of years [ __ ] all
then
i mean that's the laws of compounding it
goes slow then it goes really fast you
would have seen that so that's clearly
one of the things but what else made you
and because there's a lot of people on
instagram giving advice and there's a
lot of fitness people and whatever else
why are you
of all of them
it's interesting where i think that
having a conversation with me now you'd
probably assume or you'd come to the
conclusion i'm different to my socials
i've always seen social media as a
crowded room where
you know a podcast is where we sat
together driving somewhere three hours
let's talk let's relax let the
conversation wonder but on instagram
and tick tock whatever i have 10 seconds
to capture your attention
and i love the idea of polarizing people
i said in my first book that
imagine you invite me to a barbecue in
shoreditch and
someone talks about formula one and i go
i [ __ ] hate formula one someone goes
what go look i just
doesn't interest me and someone's like
you think he bought him the first time
and he's [ __ ] on formula one
ten people at the bbq three of them be
like do you know what i also agree with
you i think it's [ __ ] and they'll
remember me for saying something
controversial
rather than oh yeah it's good isn't it
oh lewis hamilton yeah so you know so
many people want to get in line with an
opinion that they're no longer
remembered
so i took it upon myself and it was
almost by accident i do my lives every
day i do videos then something would
piss me off
and i'm not a violent person so i just
channel it into a video and it would get
a lot more likes and shares and i was
like hold on what's going on here so
again i would post 10 videos it would be
the one where i was a bit more
aggressive
and over time
i learnt
that there were certain things people
wanted in a certain way
and it wasn't the six packs the chicken
and broccoli the food prep it was being
passionate without compromise about
different topics
and
i do swear as a person i am crass i am
vulgar and i do make very inappropriate
analogies for things
i put that out
like i said i only ever wanted 10
clients i only ever wanted 10 clients so
if half the people that see a video hate
me for it that's fine because as long as
the other half is 10 people that would
do business with me again i'm invincible
and i've always had that mentality that
i only need 10 people like me to make a
living
and if i do those 30 hours at 150 pounds
an hour six hours between 6 am and 2 pm
i can live a dream life and be wealthy
even though it's barely breaking 100 to
200k a year
as long as i can buy dinner for my
friends and family i can be wealthy with
10 people and
people
completely misconstrue social media for
that they go i need everyone to like me
i need a million people to like me
you know i first flew first class with
28 000 followers and you don't need that
many people to like you to do well and i
wish i wish people could understand that
because
social media has become a popularity
contest it's not this is not a
popularity contest
this is
a means of you getting people over the
line to like you enough to do business
with you
it's so true i i did a lot of talking on
stage where i was looking at people like
pierce morgan and
kanye west and
katie hopkins and what what you've
described there is what i've always said
which is you don't have to like these
people but the conversation orbits
around them now your barbecue analogy
there
by you saying oh the formula formula one
is [ __ ] everyone then
comes over to you and the conversation
is centers around james's opinion
and that brings attention to you i said
to my friends last night because i did a
tweet and it's got 20 000 likes and it's
like going [ __ ] crazy and everyone's
talking about it i said listen you're
not going to be able to build a personal
brand in 2022 if you're not i said this
my friend my friends last night now
what's up group if you're not prepared
for someone to call you a
[ __ ]
if you're not if you're not willing to
accept someone calling you a [ __ ] it's
going to be incredibly hard to get um
the attention you need for the
algorithms to turn in your favor and
that means in your case and as i've seen
from many just being yourself
and but there's a cost there is but you
can be selective with this as well
so
uh if i have an argument against the
keto diet yeah i don't advocate the keto
diet so if a load of people that are
zealots in the realm of the ketogenic
diets hate me that's fine i'm starting
fire on someone else's property then you
know
i support vegan from an ethical
standpoint but i don't like this
self-righteous
uh you know sanctimonious element of
veganism like it's been hijacked a bit
like um i've often said like feminism
what a fantastic cause hijacked by a few
to give it a bad sometimes bad rap
veganism is the same but then i can have
a little bit of a cheap shot and joke
you know satire content with a vegan and
suddenly oh the vegans are up and i'm
sharing this this is unacceptable again
i've started fire on someone else's
property and the people you've
cultivated to like you go that's
actually really funny or you know so
you can be very selective with who you
pick arguments with i did one about
bodybuilding where
i said hey if you want to
you know diet down for six months to
show off your insecurities versus
someone else's cover yourself from fake
tan and call it a sport you do you right
the bodybuilder community went mental
and everyone was like is this guy stupid
he's a personal trainer i don't coach
bodybuilders
yet thousands of them shared my post my
following went up and little did they
realize it was their followers that may
be invested in them but don't agree with
their values they went hold on i'm
supposed to hate this guy but i agree
with them
and now they're either on me not someone
else
being selectively hated is brilliant and
now
i even look to
the comment section for new content
someone goes james well when are you
going to start training chess
i'm like hey man when are you going to
start you know stop going on people's
profiles you don't follow to make
content you know there are so many like
arguments now that i can see from the
negative comments that i can then turn
into content
so
again it's one of those things where
people need to appreciate there is a
power in being disliked and
if i turn up
to you know an event that's supposed to
be fully booked and
it's not got bums in every seat i might
go right i might need to you know reign
it in and really reconsider what i do
for a living but as long as
the talks i do have people in them as
long as i'm still getting support for
what i'm doing i feel like i must be
tiptoeing the line enough like i say
it's it's passion without compromise i
must say what i feel
and i don't care i think with seneca if
you don't wish to be criticized do
nothing say nothing be nothing
and
you know that's how i feel and are you
being yourself or are you playing a
character
it's always caffeinated james you know
me when i've had three coffees that's
who people get
behind the scenes i'm a bit more relaxed
quite happy to disagree with people
because there isn't uh
an interest in it for me someone walks
past me on the street saying i love
formula one i'm like hey mate come back
yeah you're fat and i hate it yeah yeah
yeah
and um and the same again where
you know i'm i'm not
argumentative away from social media if
i see people you know chat and hate
about me i don't get involved in it i'm
not really that that person
um
what about joe wicks what about that
beef do you know what
stats stirred the pot there a little bit
you said some comments to him about
um he said there's some dishonesty there
um
regarding what he does so
this is something where i haven't gone
back on my word but about six months ago
i took the podcast i did about them
offline
no i just i felt like i've been a bit
harsh you know at the time i've got ten
thousand followers about my first taste
of growth on social media and like beef
and rappers you need an arch enemy you
know you need someone to be able to go
out so you can kind of go back and forth
i actually emailed joe about four years
ago five years seven years ago
and um i emailed him and i i found out
that you'd seen one of my videos
and i thought oh [ __ ] i never expected
him to see it ever i was
posting content i was oh my god i might
have heard someone's feelings i emailed
him i said hey joe just to let you know
one i will be coming for you a bit but
two you never get put down by people
above you that's all i said
and he emailed me back
ages ago and
i continued the endeavour and there were
still things did he say
not coming back i i think he said
something on the lines of he hadn't had
an email like that before it didn't stop
me though so there were a few things
that
frustrated me
one
i don't like people blanket prescribing
solutions to people i don't and there's
i don't like anyone that presents a
solution without education you know the
teacher man to fish
analogy so
i had clients that were paying me but
also bought as plan so straight away
there's a bit of a conflict and i
remember looking through the supplements
that
and i was like why aren't you amino
acids lucy and i was like well i don't
know why you're popping these leucine
pills from my protein they're massive
like a pelican trying to swallow each
one i was like unless you're vegetarian
or vegan you don't need this then the
branched cheese amino acids and i was
like
you don't really need to be consuming
another six pills with this and then
i was like from an ethical standpoint i
don't these people are very over
supplemented for jumping around the
front room
then there was the one-size-fits-all
plan one of my clients was a type one
diabetic who got sent it and i was like
don't need that no this is not you know
specialized for you
and the amount of volume that was being
given to people is it's very easy to
make people tired this is what
frustrates me as a trainer i actually
want to stimulate people in the gym get
them moving
and if there was ever a boundary of the
maximum they could do i want to come
under that every day a lot of people are
stressed under slept undernourished
smashing people in their front room
every day i don't think is the solution
out of this so i picked some holes in
the programming pick some holes in uh
you know the supplement
issue there but the main problem is this
people would have gone there seen him on
tv gmtv seen the book sales and gone
this is my savior
and when they fail the plan or don't
finish it which i think a lot of people
do i think i'm not saying that
objectively they blame themselves and
this is what kills me
so many people maybe hundreds of
thousands of people would have done a
one-size-fits-all plan all doing the
same exercise regime i could not sustain
hit training at 32 every day in my front
room it would break me
when they do eventually fall off that
and the meal plan cooking everything
from scratch which again i mean we're
sitting next to hill that's a market
that's come off the back of people not
wanting to cook from scratch when they
fail that plan they're going to blame
themselves and the voices in their head
are going to say i didn't want it enough
i'm not motivated i'm not committed i'm
not cut out for this and you hear my
voice now this is something i'm
passionate about
it breaks me to think of the tens of
thousands of people who gave up on their
ambitions because they went the wrong
way for advice
if people love hit and they love cooking
from scratch this guy is probably the
guy for you join his plan not mine
but
it almost felt like
physics so many people went to something
it created gravity that other people
went and
it's my
feeling that let a lot of people down
and if it didn't i wouldn't have
experienced so much growth from pointing
out the inadequacies
if people were truly happy i would have
been shut the hell up then and i would
have just gone away and not existed on
social media so what's your plan how
does it differ
imagine uh we have you the consumer
selling i'm selling you're the consumer
the principal of fat loss is a calorie
deficit in fact that we need to create
an injury deficit um just for anybody
that doesn't understand that means
burning more calories than you're
consuming and it doesn't make it simple
science but you know let's just say to
people like money in the bank analogy if
you earn too much then you spend you're
going to recruit money in the bank that
is what fat is it's not from toxins it's
not from you know whatever you're led to
believe
now everything in between those two how
it works in the person is a method you
know keto 5'2 intermittent fasting all
of these are methods that dress up the
principle for the consumer it's almost
packaging something for the person
with me
rather than giving them the method first
i put them straight in bed with the
principal and i say look
this is how many calories i think you
burn on a daily basis i think you should
try eating 15 less than that here's a
protein target go away if it works we've
hit it if it doesn't we're still too
high if you gain weight you know we've
really missed the mark here
this is how it works
really educate people to all the things
they need to go like a driving
instructor i should not exist in your
life in six months apart from the guy
that taught you to drive
why is it so acceptable for people to
invest money into fitness professionals
and still be there three years later the
pt model is almost flawed in some
respects if you do your job well enough
your client leaves
so
for me even when my clients i had face
to face for years i was on gym for four
years
i said look you're gonna pay me more
than the rate that you pay anyone else
but in three months time if you can't do
this on your own i'll give you your
money back because i should be
people arrive at fitness like getting in
the car for the first time they're like
what the hell is the third pedal that's
a clutch a clutch dad well that was a
clutch i remember learning to drive i
thought there was go and stop
and rather than just getting in the car
and driving i need to explain to him we
need this to change gears the indicator
must be done before we start to break
this is your mirrors and the fitness
world doesn't have that anymore there
needs to be some ruthlessness with this
when i say to people look
this is the education you need you need
to learn how to do this for yourself
it's one of those things where i have a
big problem with people
monetizing and not giving that solution
you know
i think it's so important that we teach
people these fundamentally so they
understand and i'm not an extremist you
look at me now i'm you know
just before downstairs
we were talking before the podcast about
have you been on the front cover of
men's health i was like no no i don't
agree with that i don't think these are
physiques that are obtainable to most
men in our country i think you know
that's like saying hey you can't be
happy to earn quarter of a million pound
yes that's great but most men won't get
there so how about we set the goal
something more realistic and middleton
another one of your guests a friend of
mine
he got criticized for not being lean
enough for the men's health cover we got
a guy climbed to mount everest you know
like oh sorry mate you're not leaning
off you haven't shaved your chest
recently enough so
it's one of those things where
i think there's a lot of
a lot of work to be done with not only
teaching people how things work but also
in setting the finish line so from
entrepreneurship you the new rich i
think is great because we have such
subjectivity between how much money your
business can make but once you get the
freedom to work remote and live your
life well done you've done it and i
think that if someone especially men can
get to the point where they're happy to
go for a job topless you've done it they
don't have to be absent if you can go
for a job topless or you can you know
wear a pair of speedos on holiday well
done mate you've done it and i think we
need to have that approach with fitness
i've had so many people tag me on
instagram even on telegram and in my
twitter dms
in a picture of them starting their heel
journey and it's one of the most
amazing things in my life that i get to
do a podcast which of course needs money
to to fuel and i have a sponsor like you
who i genuinely believe is going to help
every single person
who starts their heel journey change
their life because this podcast the
central intention of this podcast is to
help people live better lives and we get
to sit here and i get to promote to you
a product which has not only helped me
change my life but it's going to help
millions of people and is helping
millions of people live a nutritionally
complete life it's so it's such an
incredible product and for me the reason
why it's incredible is because it gives
me my protein it gives me my vitamins
minerals it's plant-based it's low in
sugar gluten-free it does all of that in
a small drink that tastes good there are
other products there's foods there's the
hot and savory collection many other
things but for me
this ready to drink is the absolute
savior of my diet throughout the week
where i'm moving at such pace
look i don't want to labor the point but
if you haven't tried you'll give it a
try and if you do
tag me instagram wherever you try it
give me a tag anyway
back to the podcast
you're in the business of helping people
change their lives hopefully that's i
guess that's i'm guessing that's part of
the goal is to help them become a better
version of themselves and a lot of
people listening to this will have a
friend or they'll have a i don't know a
family member or someone
that they they want to help change their
life what have you learned about those
that actually do take the steps commit
change their lives and those that just
kind of say it
and how do you are you able to identify
them super early and say this person's
got no chance is there like a warning
sign where you go this person's just all
talk and you give up at some point on
people uh face-to-face i had to because
there was a finite amount of energy in
which i could give people and i had to
stack clients and i'm sorry someone
could take your slot pay me the same
amount of money but i can make progress
with them
and sometimes they come back a different
person
the main thing i learned
i wrote the first book not a diet book
and then i realized there was a
precursor and
my theory is that you know in my videos
in my content i say fat people i say
obese and i use the [ __ ] word openly
but
i don't think
people are gluttonous and greedy i think
that yeah from an evolutionary
standpoint it makes sense that if we're
surrounded by copious amounts of hedonic
food that we should be consuming it
because we have done hundreds of
thousands of years but people don't want
to be this way
so i came to realize that so many people
before we look at calorie deficit we
need to look at other pressing issues
do you like your work life do you like
your relationships because
if you come home from a work you're not
passionate about from a job you're not
passionate about and you walk straight
in through the door to a relationship
you're not passionate about
me telling you to eat less means doing
less of the only thing you might enjoy
every day so there's a big life
constructionist issue that
comes up and actually i find as a pt i
was asking this i was like you guys are
you're always moaning about your
boyfriend why
why don't you break up oh we've been
together five years and since now i now
know that's the sunk cost fallacy
whether making a decision based off the
previous investment not the actual
reason if they want to be in a
relationship so with the second book i
was like well before we even get into
this commitment wanting it do i give up
on this person i'm like right we've got
steve repetitive yo-yo dieter
sticks to the death tip three weeks then
he falls off okay steve mitch you like
your job you know do you like it
now well i've been there eight years do
you like your relationship steve oh no
i'm you know i'm mister in my head and
all the other way around
sabrina's like my boyfriend's a wanker
whatever it is and i've come to realize
that if we can help change those things
in those people's lives suddenly
everything else seems a lot
a lot easier there's a lot less
boundaries a lot less effort so
in a cheesy way
we almost need to address the
foundations that people are building on
because if you haven't got this and
again
imagine you're in a job you hate on 50k
and you take a pay cut and start a
venture with your best mate for 30k
you're gonna have less pleasure in your
life less expensive trainers less
private jets whatever
but suddenly you have a job you enjoy
and if you're getting enough
satisfaction between seven when you wake
up and four when you come home you won't
need to get it from food
and then they drop a bit of weight and
then they start feeling better and then
they go oh you know what i could do with
a bit of muscle on this arm so then they
start going to the gym and then they
make friends there and
so this whole
conversation surrounding you know
motivation
i don't think it's a positive charge of
motivation i think that too many people
are carrying a negatively charged career
and a negatively charged relationship
status so you view like a
poor relationship with your diet or food
as more of a symptom of
negativity or lack of fulfillment or
lack of satisfaction in other areas of
your life because i've actually been
there when i worked in uh so i worked in
sales and i hate phone calls so it was
the wrong job for me i don't even know
when people call me i'm like what do you
want they're like what do you mean
are you you're right i'm fine until you
called me so um and i used to get to
work i used to have pin nutella
sandwiches two slices of toast i wasn't
even hungry peanut butter and one
nutella and the other put them together
i'm having a 500 calorie just a bit of
toast just to kill time from my mundane
existence in my office again there are
so many people doing this and in my time
in corporate i realized
people are doing the absolute bare
minimum to get by and i always say to
people the second you join a big
corporate
business they're going to pay you the
least amount of money for the most
amount of your life
and if you don't construct how you want
your life to look they're going to do it
and a lot of people
don't like how that construction looks
like and then they wonder why they're
feeling malaise or you know depressed or
disheartened and it's because you let
someone else build your life for you and
it's very important for people to
unattach from that and then
if they can
and this is another thing where
i'm sure you'll be able to relate to
some of the best things that have ever
happened in my life have come off the
back of opportunities not going my way
and my back's been against the wall oh
yeah um
i'll probably get shot saying this
during an event uh later on this year at
sydney opera house which is mad massive
which
for me is
an incredible incredible feat because
four years ago i remember being so
skinned
in sydney living in a hostel that i went
to opera bar to apply for a job behind
the bar
and they said you have to have a
qualification serve our cars i'm not
doing
i remember reading uh tim ferriss's
tours of the titans on the ferry back to
where i lived and it goes if someone put
a gun to your head would you work harder
i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah i would i would call up all my
existing clients i'd get referrals then
i call those referrals and i close them
for sales i give them money back
guarantees i would quite literally just
do a lot more and then i came to realize
okay i'm gonna go home and do that and
within five months i joined fitness
first and then bought my way out of it
and
it's crazy that people are so afraid of
being in this position where they leave
a career they're unfulfilled with that
they're going to be stuck and lost
but anything when your back's against
the wall you find another version of
yourself that works harder and does more
and puts itself into uncomfortable
situations and my favorite thing to say
to someone is like
how many times have you let yourself
down really in your life how many times
have you really woken up and gone i've
really let myself down and even if you
have
you got out of it and most people they
haven't and why the hell do you think
you're going to let yourself down now
where's that come from where's that
[ __ ] assumption come from probably
the people you hang around with probably
the naysayers in your life that may be
saying it because they want to protect
you
and
so many people in that kind of world of
just
not fulfillment and i always say again
please do not mistake
passion with being good at something
because if i get you to do anything for
three years you're going to be good at
it
don't call that passion you do
recruitment for three years and you can
close people oh yeah straight here 50
100 i'll get them top four whatever it
doesn't mean you're passionate about it
means you're good at it and people
really need to distinguish that
there's going to be a ton of people
listening to this now that are in that
situation they're in a they're on their
way to a job this morning you know that
they don't particularly like
and but they're going to say well james
i've got a mortgage to pay and i've got
a couple of kids you know you'll get
this a lot of time because i get it i
get every day got a couple of kids and
it's easy for you guys to say because
you you know you're single and you've
got all this money now but i can't just
leave this call center james i've got
timmy that needs to go to school and i
need to you know buy his books for his
book bag and what you say to those
people that are feeling like they've
they've kind of built a wall too big to
climb over it's a very difficult one and
again i can never say
or just do this
because when i'm talking now i'm talking
to james of 22. similarly to how you
would talk to yourself at 18.
i can't talk to every age group
listening to this podcast so i'll try to
talk to the one i know best yeah but
there's two kind of ways out
there's one where some people do need to
make a risk because
they may see no options now but where
are they going to be in five years
a lot of the time things get worse with
time not better in these situations
unfulfillment
passionless existence all of these
things get worse if your relationship is
on the rocks you don't just give it four
years something needs to be done
sometimes you do need to rip the cord
but to people who are genuinely past it
because people did read my second book
and go well i just can't do this
i said to them well okay
make sure your kids know this
make sure if there's one valiant thing
you do is fall on the sword and say
right
for me i will sit out the next 10 years
but those kids every time i talk to them
every day they're at the dinner table
every step they make in life install
that into them
my dad said to me like my whole life
he's just always said you're a long time
dead he always just drawed it into me my
whole life every time i've wanted to do
something sorry i'm gonna be a long time
dead son
and
there's no it helps me understand there
is no time to to dwell to wait to see
things out and i think that
again that's one of the things that
people don't think about enough
you know we're all slowly dying such a
weird thing to think about
people all right just give it a few more
years
you don't have that time isn't on our
side our existence as a human being is
if the universe could talk it would
laugh at the amount of time we have to
live
and some people again
what's the worst that could truly happen
you've got a mortgage call
have you got enough to survive two
months
two months and if you can't give
everything to something for two months
maybe don't do it at all
personal trainers as well they say this
all the time at my business talks oh you
know they're doing minimum wage hours
six seven pounds an hour wiping down
machines between trying to run a
legitimate business and they're afraid
to go alone
okay if i gave you seven pounds for that
hour and put you on a gym floor
and gun to that mentality you need to
make a business we're going to wipe down
machines for your whole life
of course they're going to do it the
intensity the audacity everything they
could give to people is going to be
incredible i think it's baffling that
people write themselves off before they
even make the decision and in some
respects
them going i've got kids i've got a
mortgage i appreciate all of those
things but
is this a [ __ ] hurdle you're putting
in front
of making change in your life i could be
wrong i don't know but it could be
they need to ask themselves that i can't
ask them that
one of the things you said that was
really interesting you said i don't feel
deserving of my success and i've heard
you talk a little bit about
imposter syndrome do you suffer with
imposter syndrome
i kind of back out of it very quickly
every time i i feel the emotion
everything to me is just weird it's just
weird people on a selfie i'm like yeah
i'm like this is a weird part of my day
let's embrace it this is something up
until 27
no one ever stopped me for a photo or
acknowledged my work 32 now give or take
15 of my life so for 85
of my life
that never happened so everything to me
is just you know i joke around at
speaking events i go hey i'm gonna get
found out soon until then i'm gonna milk
this for everything i can
i do i do feel it a lot
it's a strange one especially at home
like uh
i got my mum and dad
someone who said oh james can i get a
picture i now sharper in my dad when he
goes into london we went to twickenham a
few weeks ago and i don't particularly
like going to watch sporting events
anymore it's cold
you know trains are so crammed all of
this but if my dad's going i'll i'll
come with you i'll make sure no one
barges into you especially when people
are excellent twickenham like [ __ ] off
and um purple belt yeah yeah watch out
mate again and um even i see it on my
dad's face he's like he's like but he he
doesn't my parents don't have social
media they don't they don't exist in
that world but i can tell they're kind
of proud of it and i was like you know
what if my parents are proud of this
weirdness
i'll embrace it and i'll be happy to
embrace it but yes it's just incredibly
strange it's again why i need someone
else to negotiate all rates and what i
get paid and speaking appearances
because whenever even getting the invite
for this podcast i was like [ __ ] you
know
i was like i hope i can keep up the
conversation for an hour
i have the biggest fear whenever i have
guests on my podcast i'm like what if i
run out of things to ask after half an
hour where does that come from that sort
of like that almost self-doubt and
almost insecurity i think that a lot of
my
confidence not not all of it
but a
big chunk of it is a facade an essential
facade
i need to play the character
confidence to me isn't about who you are
it's about who you need to be it's about
how how i need to talk in this interview
how i need to present myself the things
i need to get passionate about
in some respects when that fades
you know i'm just a pt on a gym floor in
bracknell i worked on a you know a
trading estate for three four years and
the craziest thing is i was happy i was
happy then i wouldn't you come meet me
four or five years ago hey james wait
how's your life i wouldn't belong you
know [ __ ] i could do with a bit more
money you know what i could do with you
know an expensive watch i was never like
that i used to ridicule my clients for
flying business and buying rolexes i was
like what a waste of money now to my
other friends i'm like you should really
try business
and um
yeah i've definitely had a complete flip
on that i don't know where it comes from
to be fair but to be be honest it's
probably a fan i spend a lot of time my
family and my friends
i don't really have any mega
successful
influencer friends so everyone's pretty
grounded and we all think that we're
getting away with murder charging money
for things
so
i think it probably comes from that
but from what you've said as well you
spent the first
at least 15 years of your life being
indirectly told that you should aim so
high and not much is going to happen in
your life right it was when i first
became a pt that has changed where i
remember listening to podcasts reading
books studying topics
and one day it clicked i was like
i'm never going to be in the best shape
never going to be the most muscular
never going to be the most experienced
and i was like i could be a good
communicator because these podcasts i'm
listening to are dull as [ __ ] i listen
to a 56 minute podcast on caffeine i
managed to turn it into an academy model
that was two and a half minutes right
that's all they needed and i thought
there's a gap in the market here and it
becomes a snowballing effect where maybe
even the same with yourself where at the
beginning you were like
i understand the operational part of the
business i understand investorship then
when you see the returns on your efforts
you're like oh i'm actually quite good
at this and you get all these
confirmations that occur along the way
and i think it's more that if i'm honest
i still
struggle
to communicate with myself that i'm with
an authority on things i actually need
external validation still quite a lot
which i've never really told anyone
before we've spoken about quite a few
things today that i've never really
spoken about and
even
there are always little battles that can
be won and lost
and some days i'm like i do lose belief
in
who i need to be
and you know what actually content
creation for me really helps me with
that because whenever i'm having a day
where i'm like
[ __ ] do i really know what i'm talking
about i will just express something i
feel wholeheartedly about and see how it
goes and when it [ __ ] blows up i go
oh maybe i do know what i'm on about
carry on that's a dangerous game to play
because on the other end
if you're if external validation is
moving you up it's like impossible for
it not to move you the other way so if
someone dms you and goes you are you're
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about vegans are
you know
this and keto akito vegan is the best
way to be
surely that moves you too no it does and
sometimes if i if i do get a really you
know harsh criticism i don't take it
from an emotional level i take it from
an objective level i actually do this a
lot if someone criticizes me on
something i go
before i think he's a [ __ ] he could
be right so i give him the benefit of
the doubt and i'll go to someone smarter
than me i'm like just to double check
i'm right on this topic and i think
that's a good way to protect myself from
it
every time someone says you're wrong on
this subject i don't go hey [ __ ] you
i've got more followers than you i'm
like oh [ __ ] i best go away and research
this and i actually use the little troll
attack sometimes to reconfirm my
position on something
if someone goes you know you swear too
much in your content
i'm like i'll reflect on it
am i swearing too much
is this how i got here dangerous game to
play that like it is we all play it i'm
not pretending i'm just playing devil's
advocate to ask good questions here but
that
yeah if you if you're relying on other
people to validate you then
their words can also invalidate you
theoretically
so do you struggle with that being
then then i would just remove myself
from the situation on the social media
side of things like okay i'd sit with my
thoughts and again do you know what i
remember you saying this word just
probably went live
psychedelics really helped me with this
but psychedelics also
got in my head
a couple times
for people
that don't know too much about
psychedelics i've always said to people
it's like therapy with yourself
you're not always the the guy that holds
all the answers but you're at least the
person that has the questions
i remember
did a magic mushroom trip
and one of the questions i was poised
with was do people like you for who you
are or what you do
i was like oh i'm in need a few weeks
how can i need a bit of time for this
because
i was like how many of my followers
actually know who i am
it's my first offense when someone
criticizes me i'm like you don't know me
i'm like oh if they don't know me what
do they like me for [ __ ]
i'm still figuring it out
so i think that there's definitely a lot
of
conversations and internal dialogues
in which that i'm still breaking down
and that's another thing that people
can't understand about psychedelics some
of the things you're poised with in
question with can take months sometimes
years to unravel
it's one of the things with building an
identity isn't it you then
it's easy to to start to believe you you
are your identity and that's not always
a helpful thing because it can take you
further and further away from who you
actually are and i think all the mental
health research is clear that when we
abandon ourselves because we've built up
a persona
then it can be very costly for the
person we truly are and i actually think
that continual faking from what i've
learned from my guests is is really
really harmful so
it must be somewhat difficult right like
creating the separation because you are
not the guy that i've met today is not
the guy that i've seen on instagram
telling me that i'm a fat prick like
it's not these aren't the same joking
these aren't the same individuals so how
do you kind of disassociate from that i
think jim curry said something about
taking the mask off
he goes depression is when you have to
take the mask off and say i don't want
to do this anymore
and for me very fortunately it's three
minutes a day i'm this person so i was
on tv start in front of loads of people
but then sometimes what i do like is
i purposely
i call it a cunsiv
i do a post
that catches all the [ __ ] in the sieve
and i sometimes purposefully as hard as
i can try and get people to unfollow me
with i just say something brutally
honest i go in as hard as i can but the
objective of losing a few thousand
followers because then i can kind of
tighten the
the area the remit of people which i
talked to
and i remember in middle of summer i was
like this is [ __ ] just honestly i was
like we're kind of out of lockdown but
we're not still got to do tests to go
travel we're pretending it's the new
normal but it's not the new normal and i
i just expressed my emotions without the
facade
and no one barely even noticed and i was
like that's that's good that means
there's not this big transient period
between i am just
in
it's not a different person it's more
enthusiasm which i think again is a very
important thing because
like
par i always say that my talks are
between a ted talk and stand up i need
to ensure that i can tiptoe the line of
retaining the audience keeping them in
entertaining the audience at the same
time so there is a requirement jimmy
carr when you met him you wouldn't if
you listened to that podcast first half
an hour you wouldn't go oh he's a funny
[ __ ] he's great this is a very
intelligent person
so i completely appreciate where he
comes from as well for me i don't think
there's too much separation i think you
wouldn't sit with me now and go
that's a completely different person you
would go okay this is an instagram james
yeah it's a caffeinated yeah um you said
the word depression now one of the
things you wrote about in your book is
anxiety as well and your own experience
with anxiety tell me about that that's
something that uh
well
you sleep with people and they can say
anything
that's one that creeps up on you over
time
where you can have i remember once
waking up to a message saying relax this
is fine it's all being dealt with but
one of your ex-girlfriends in a
facebook group community for months has
said do you think it's okay if i make up
a story about my ex i will take the
money from the story and give it to my
son
so we had that screenshot we had that
locked down so if it did go to the press
straight away we can have it taken down
and i was like wow
i thought we were on good terms 10 years
ago or whatever it was
and that then gets your mind working you
go
what if i rub someone the wrong way what
if someone changes their stance on you
what if you know i have a joking
authorization with someone in a bar
which they then misconstrue
what if
i genuinely want to you know be ignorant
on a subject and someone construes that
as a facetious attempt to insult someone
so
there's a lot of anxiety that i carry
because not everyone watching is
watching you succeed a lot of people
watching you want to see you fall and
they're waiting at that very opportunity
and that is quite tough because
there are going to be a lot of people
that are out to just
not see me be happy
so that's where the anxiety stems from a
lot of the time you have the general
life anxiety like oh i hope you don't
get cancer this year you know one of
those things i've had friends that never
made it to 30. some of my rugby
teammates
that you know
find a lump in the testicle on a friday
boat's off by sunday dead within 10
months and
i think about that a lot so i think it's
important to have that anxiety as well
i'm not guaranteed to live to 60. you
know i'm not guaranteed to
see my book release so for the
publishers i get finished but
so there's there are anxieties but i
work proactively to override them you
know
uh mark twain
i've had many
worries in my life most of which never
happened
so
i think that i've got the wisdom
especially of stoics to
these
anxious traits are not new they've
existed for a lot longer than we could
imagine
so you do carry that around
i get drunk you know or did i put
something on the story you know
i know that drunk james can say things
but i know he'd never do things he's not
inappropriate he's not a groper he's not
disrespectful to women or any of those
things so i'm fine with that but then i
do carry this
small amount of anxiety because the
higher you climb the further you fall
and
when you feel like your life is a fairy
tale
you hope it has the fairy tale ending
and you're like
i hope i'm not the one that you know
this is going too well it's like you're
a gambling table you keep winning on red
eventually i'm gonna lose everything i
think about that a lot so i think that's
what keeps me straight how do you defend
yourself from being cancelled what's
your sort of philosophy
for that for me
my my thing and aunt middleton i think
reaffirmed this for me jordan peterson
reaffirmed this for me as well is
if i never can try to convince anybody
that i'm something i'm not if i never
try and convince them that i'm like a
really good guy or that i'm like morally
perfect they'll never be able to call
that contradiction and really a lot of
the time people getting cancelled is
because
they've um tried to pull the wool of
your eyes about their like moral compass
and it explains why jimmy car can sit
here and go i mean this is slightly
different because it's comedy but jimmy
car can sit there and go oh [ __ ] the
over 70s the delta variant wiped them
out all rappers can talk about all the
misogynistic things they talk about
whatever no one's going to leave any
hate on their videos or because they
never gave us the expectation of other
otherwise it's usually the people that
quite often it's the people that
are our prime ministers or our
politicians or have inherited this moral
high ground that we go oh
you had a christmas party
it's i'm i stand with very controversial
opinions as well surrounding i'm very
pro-drug legalization i think that you
know
i've got family members in the police
force i wish they were dealing with real
real crime yeah and i think that we
could abolish a lot of drug related
crimes by legalization i think we should
tax and wish equality control i don't
think it's going to be a net positive
for society but i don't think exactly
right now it is any better so with
stand points like that and people go
james have you done cocaine i go yes you
know have you done mdma yeah last
weekend you know i'll always be honest
with people and that does give you a
drop off for followers but the concept
of i've got i thought them out early so
that they can come in they can go and
that's not to be sexist or to talk about
female genitalia that is to
use another polarizing word so i'll be
transparent with that similar to danny
dyer got caught and sees tv doing a line
and i was like it's just danny you know
that's what i mean
there is there is the
the anti you know cancelable effect of
that uh you know even
when single being very transparent with
needs and wants
through messages so that if someone was
to look through you know a trail of it
you'd be like wow he made it very clear
that was the position he was in so i'm
always trying to maintain an
anti-cancelable thing i haven't got tv i
haven't got radio
i've actually probably had
12 minutes of tv time in four or five
years i think because a lot of tv
networks don't want to get cancelled so
um
if you were to pull the plug on all my
media tomorrow
i'd probably see a one percent drop off
on an engagement and
you know i'm very honest with all my
clientele the people that really matter
to me
book buyers academy members and talk
attendees
i don't believe that any of my actions
would ever deter them from their
interest in me
which kind of makes me uncomfortable you
know
yeah and i'm not too worried about that
i've been thinking a lot lately about
like
there's a few types of imprisonment in
life there's physical imprisonment you
can put me in a jail and the other type
of imprisonment which i think is
probably even worse is like the mental
imprisonment which is we're gonna decide
what you can think and say
um
and who you are and like i really don't
want that so how do i have to design my
life to make sure that i never get
mentally imprisoned do i never go to
mental jail and one of them is building
enough resources so that even if you
turned off my revenue streams the ones
you could turn off i'm still good the
other is things like this which is this
is my own show don't sell it to spotify
or someone else because then
there is a guy that could pull the plug
and i really i've really started to
think about this idea of like
designing an uncancelable life so that
you could be mentally free in a world
where we're all [ __ ] virtue signaling
and trying to fit in and be correct
you know jail i like that one like it
isn't that on book three yeah yeah yeah
it's a race well you can get in there
but first i think um yeah you're
incredibly correct and i think that you
know i don't have a huge amount in
savings but i think i could live three
years on that you know i went to i went
to asia for six months when i was
younger and in six months i spent three
and a half thousand pounds yeah i wasn't
staying in the nicest places but
i spent time there so sometimes i'm like
hey if the world goes to [ __ ] i got 10
years in thailand let's go i'll just
train jiu jitsu don't cost me anything
laundry whatever so i always do that and
i actually i wrote about this one of my
books i remember i ate in a steak
restaurant in sydney once on the beach
and the waiter that served this really
nice guy a young guy and then i looked
at him and i went oh i could have your
life you know
you probably serve steak in the
restaurant probably get good tips you're
in sydney your prayer works 6 p.m to 11
most nights maybe five six nights a week
i could surf during the day and get a
dog and train jiu jitsu
if i was to do that every day for the
next 30 years i would have a better life
than 99 of people on the planet
so with the cancelable thing i almost
think like if i was to get cancelled oh
i won't have to use my phone as much
you know as long as i can get into a
country that i that i genuinely love
i always say to myself i'll open a
jujitsu dojo in a small town in
australia i've got door knocking
experience i use the doorknob for
empower i used to have to knock on 100
to sell gas and electric to people that
already had gas and electric
how much easier would it be to sell
jujitsu memberships hey calm down first
weeks free whatever
i in the same way not only like to have
the uncountable life i like to have a
out plan that can sometimes be better
than my current existence so it's one of
those things where i was like um yeah i
do think about that a lot and that's why
your family trusts isn't it no exactly
right anything but no i think it is one
of those things where especially with
dragons then and you're going on bbc
there is a expectation of of who you are
and the mental journal you talk about i
experienced in the corporate world where
i was in recruitment high-end
recruitment and then said what'd you get
up to the weekend the truth was i was on
an away bus to exeter playing rugby and
i got a dick of the day so we had to do
edward seider hands where they duct tape
bottles of cider to my hands and i had
to drink about three liters of cider
pretty much to break myself free they
put a bin bag around me and i puked in
it for the most way back i was like yeah
went out for dinner my friends
and then having that same conversation
everyone good weekend oh lovely thanks
went after my friends
i couldn't even express myself
which is
you do feel like you're behind bars and
i just have to wear a shirt and tie
clean shaven i wasn't even client facing
most time and i get i'd get [ __ ] for not
shaving
and where i just wanted to go why do i
need to [ __ ] shave i'd be like okay
yeah of course i'll get the pick out
tomorrow it
and that builds up
that angst builds up and for a lot of
people that do suffer mental gel i think
that's another reason martial arts saves
them they can save their anks they can
save that frustration and channel it
later in the day
i have big worries over people that
don't have an outlet for breaking out of
jail oh yes yeah and they probably then
turn to alcohol and violence again and
punch-ups or whatever it is so i feel
that human beings i believe we're quite
combative i think that you watch kids
have play fights they're not trying to
hurt each other sometimes they are
give them a set of rules get them into
it let them express that but yeah the
two things one if people are in that
mental gel they need a way out to
express them
and if they are in a mental gel they
need to create long-term solutions to
not be in there because
not expressing yourself in life like you
say i've never thought of it like i
think that's really profound mental jail
where in some sense being mentally
behind bars must be harder than even
worse yeah you see and one of the
examples i've given on this podcast a
number of times is in their lgbtq
community where because they are when
people are unable to express even their
sexuality the suicide rates go up
you know before they've quote unquote
don't like the time but come out the
closet and when you look at the things
that are prescribed in the more holistic
mental health treatments as being good
for mental health it's things like
um creating music or doing art or even
like dancing and like things like yoga
and expression for me is something that
i learned later in life is actually
writing books or doing a podcast i mean
that's therapy right that's when people
go to therapy they do they express
themselves they let it out look at men
that don't express themselves it's the
single biggest killer of suicide so
let's think so we know mental prison is
a real thing and we know the
consequences are severe the question
becomes how much are you imprisoning
yourself mentally
how much are you doing that in your
day-to-day life how much like and you're
completely right and i'm so glad that's
where you went with it which is like
you need to find a way in your life
where you get a chance to express
yourself
the cell walls are closing in on that
jail you've got to find a way whether
it's [ __ ] this is why this is why i
got a bit of a problem with the nature
of social media in the
and
you're marked on how correct you are not
how
true to yourself you are it's all about
correctness typically it's funny because
it's actually not but it feels like it
is we've seen it i mean the reason part
of the reason why you identified
yourself as winning was because you
weren't correct
but it feels like the the rewards are
reserved for those that are correct
pierce morgan's the same the most
uncorrect like uncorrect person you'll
meet you know look at the [ __ ]
numbers he's this guy though you know so
i don't i'm very passionate about that
topic of it's interesting you say that
because
today if people go back and actually
listen to me talking about adoption
they'll see that i'm struggling to talk
about it because i've never i've spoken
about it maybe 10 times in my life to
that extent ever online offline whatever
yeah we've never met before but the
medium in which we've decided to
communicate being podcasting has allowed
us to both express our true deep
emotions surrounding situations which is
this dynamic in which has been created
with you know the
listening world of people that are
interested in two people colliding i
think it's great and like you say it's
incredibly therapeutic
and
it's so difficult now to create a medium
of distractions conversation
where you know
it's it's almost
a dying breed but at the same time being
re-energized by people looking to sit
down and do it
conversations dying i
two years ago went away to melbourne
with two friends i said i'm [ __ ] sick
to death for social media we're going
away with no electronic devices
and i couldn't believe how deep our
conversations were at dinner no phones
and um we get to melbourne and my friend
comes around the corner and he just has
had a p he goes mate this looks like a
comedy sketch i'm there with a sudoku
book he thought he's like i thought you
were taking the piss i thought you were
trying to make me laugh as i came around
the corner you're genuinely in the
sudoku book i was like yeah what am i
going to do for us today we went to the
cinema without our phones we went out
for dinner without our phones and the
conversations we were having were so
much more in-depth i was uncovering
problems that my friends were having i
was like i live with you and you've not
told me this
and uh yeah it's one of those things
where
i'm very grateful to podcast him because
it allows me to get a lot of my chest as
well yeah and
like you say there aren't mediums for
people to get things off their chest
whether physical or verbal
and
i just hope that the way the world's
moving becomes more like that and again
if you want to express yourself on
social media for me
doing that was the win
not the followers that i was recruiting
from it that was a bonus there was like
salt and pepper on top of the meal
just putting something i felt strongly
out every day made me feel good that's
what i got addicted to same by email
writing the emails is what made me feel
good
the what happens after that from a
business perspective is erroneous
irrelevant it doesn't really matter so
there's so many people out there even if
you do a podcast and 10 people are
listening maybe you've won the battle
before they've downloaded it i think
that the more people that can understand
that the better
quick one this is maybe a good segue to
talk about a little bit of an
announcement i have to make which is we
have a brand new sponsor for the podcast
and some of you who've seen my social
media posts will know that i often wear
a lot of jewelry and the brand that i'm
wearing when you see the chains on is a
brand called crafted as you can see on
the table in front of me if you're
watching this on youtube crafted are
brands that sell really meaningful
affordable men's jewelry so i reached
out to the founders of crafted alex and
danny and asked them if they wanted to
sponsor the podcast and they said they
did they listen to the podcast they like
what we do here the podcast is a place
of meaning and their jewelry is all
about meaning and so we forged a new
partnership the piece of jewelry i wear
the most i want to introduce you to the
pieces and why i wear them is this sand
timer unsurprising thing for me about
sand timers it's probably the most clear
reminder that our time here on earth is
finite so as the episodes go on i'll
introduce a piece of jewelry and i'll
tell you the meaning it has for me and
why i wear it
let's talk about love then you mentioned
love a couple of times you referenced
that you weren't so good at it by
what you were saying there in terms of
romantic relationships and love what's
your uh what's james like when it comes
to that department this is interesting
because
i feel already do you ever criticize
yourself before someone's criticized you
i get in there early people i always
think about what they're going to say
yes okay so yeah so then they go well in
the last 10 years you haven't had a
relationship that lasted over a year
correct
does that make me bad at relationships
or good because i will not i will not
and this could be an idealistic utopian
desire that i may i could be completely
wrong on this but whenever i have the
feeling that this ain't it i'm out
i could either be a genius or
i could have a fixed mindset when it
comes to relationships this is what i'm
figuring out
business something goes bad i'm like
mate leave it with me give me a laptop
prep baguette and a coffee let's do this
give me my phone i'll sort it out
relationships i'm like nah there's no
hope
there's no hope sorry
uh i've also i've got [ __ ] before for
breaking up my text
sometimes i'm like i should need to deal
with this now they're like oh me
tomorrow i'm like no i can't sleep until
i deal with this
sorry this isn't working out we can meet
tomorrow if you want but i'm ending it
now so
it's a two-sided sword where one i think
that
i have these utopian standards that one
day
i'll be able to turn around and go i was
correct this is what i wanted and the
other side the other part of my
conscious is like
maybe you're not willing to do the work
like you would in other areas of your
life do you value
the
i guess the idea but do you would you
value a
romantic relationship in your life yeah
i would very much like
so
psychedelic experience i had in the last
year was
really helped me decide i want to have
kids it was you do want to have kids i
don't want to have kids yeah like one
because
when i have a child it'd be the only
biological relative i've ever met which
is a powerful thing i think that's going
to be
incredible for me like to see my
features in another human that blows my
mind and it gets me very excited so
there's that and i remember me and my
friend and some people straight away
will be angry that i'm talking about
legal drug use but me and my friend put
our phones down for 10 hours went to a
park with a picnic had a speaker and we
sat opposite a lake
and we just talked [ __ ] out and i
remember this dad coming by with his kid
and they had bread to give the ducks
and i was like i was kind of watching
not in a creepy way
and i thought to myself like this is
what life is the dad
at some point gives it over to the sun
the sun then gives it over to the duck
and i was like what shame it'd be if the
kid refused to give the bread to the
duck i was like what a sad ending to the
story that would be and i went off in my
mind thinking about life and thinking
about the opportunity and my parents
sacrificed a lot for me you know they
had to go to the adoption home it's but
spend years they had to you know my mum
was infertile she couldn't have kids
they went through so much trauma
to get day one with me and i thought
[ __ ] and then from day one till now
the school runs the me being a [ __ ]
as a teenager
puberty i was bad like all of these
things and i think
everything i have now that i love is
because of the sacrifices they made
and with life i think soon my time will
come to make that same sacrifice
i have to pay this forward i think that
i'll be hardwired to want to
so sometimes when i'm 32 and i'm
thinking [ __ ] i need to start focusing
on love more because
i don't want to be 40 with the most
money the most followers and have no one
around me when all my friends settled
down and had families and i'm the creepy
[ __ ] uncle who's banging hot 22 year
olds every weekend
i don't want that so i need to make sure
that i don't arrive at the wrong finish
line that's a very very important thing
that'll be the worst thing in the world
why
because i think ultimately the the only
way we can really enjoy things is to
share them with people and this is my
favorite thing i've ever done my money
is is buy people ludicrous things
you know i with my friends i lied to
them i say to them um i'm banging a girl
who works for ba give me your flight
details i'll get you upgraded and then
i'll upgrade them and they'll hate me
for it they'll let you [ __ ] break you
shouldn't have done that you know but
then when they land wherever they got
and they're like mate that was the best
flight of my life i love doing that and
i'd love to do that in a family setting
as well
the look on a kid's face when they go on
holiday or or whatever it is
and
for me
that's an integral part spending money
on yourself is a short-term fix i think
if you buy something for yourself it's
pleasure if you buy something someone
else is happiness
if i buy myself a lamborghini i'll be
excited for three months if i buy
someone else a lamborghini i'll be
excited for the whole time they drive it
so the prospect of family to me is not
only a long-term investment into their
lives but the long-term investment into
my own happiness and
you know it's like an ultimate project
for me that i'm really excited about and
i think that
one of the most important and integral
things i value about
financial freedom and working on you a
few hours a day is
my dad said this to me once i'll never
forget him saying it he goes i wish i'd
spent more time with you when you were
growing up to me and my sister i was
like [ __ ] like dad
like you know he he commuted to the city
every day 50 years worked in the same
company king william street 50 years
and so he would leave the house at 6 30
and get back at 7 pm and when i heard
that i was like
one i never felt that way but two i
won't make that same mistake
so for me it's going to be a big part of
my life in time to then set someone else
up
to experience everything i've
experienced because if i do that right
dying might be such a big problem like
now my biggest problem is that if i did
you know and i hate to say it don't want
to jinx myself but they get cancer next
year my biggest regret would not be
having kids
i hate to talk about tragic illnesses or
whatever
but one of my very good friends
his name is paula lima he was very badly
affected by covet and he had to be
hospitalized he was in hospital bed
which is funny because he's quite
literally a fitness model if you look at
the maxim muscle types of protein he was
the six-pack on the front really so um
incredible shape all of that and i said
to him what was it like and he goes i'm
just so happy i had my kids and that
they'll be looked after he was like that
he almost had a
he won't mind me saying this a sense of
accomplishment on quite literally what
could have been his deathbed i thought
[ __ ] i could do with some of that
it's so remarkable how you see people's
lives and priorities switch when they
have kids and you just you know it's
coming because all of my friends that
have had kids they always say i wish i'd
done it sooner or
there's this later
sense of meaning that we're yet to
discover have you ever thought about
so let's say
human beings as we know them have
existed for hundreds of thousands of
years
the lineage the amount of grandparents
great great grandparent how many how
many times has a baby
been produced in that lineage
thousands
all it took all it would ever take
through hundreds of thousands of years
of lineage was one person to not want to
do it or you know they obviously didn't
have quite the choice back then but all
it would have taken was one person to
break that chain and so many of us
wouldn't exist now
i think about this all the time
like
my biological mother who gave me up for
adoption she could have ended the chain
there
if anything you know i'm still very much
pro-choice and i feel like i have a
voice to say that because if my
biological mother had chosen to abort me
then i wouldn't have a life
all it would take is one break in that
chain of lineage for me not to exist and
i'm like that's too much hard work
that's going on before me you think the
majority of the human race has existed
in poverty in the cold in famine and all
of these things i'm like
i can't stop the buck here for what a
selfish life you know for layings and to
get a full night's sleep
i once asked my followers on instagram
whether they regretted having kids and
the poll
substantially was more in favor of
people regretting it but i think really
yeah it was it was quite literally if
you could go back and not have kids
would you
and it was like a 49 51 but
it's circumstantial
i can imagine they're like yeah you know
what the grass is always green all right
you have kids they keep you awake the
little [ __ ] all of this stop you having
sex with your wife whatever it is and
it's all too easy to just go off like
yeah you know i wish i had my young life
yet but
i've never truly met
a rich successful single person without
kids with a life that i envy
i mean like even dambozerian right yeah
yeah yeah i quite i i don't idealize him
i've just listened to somebody's podcast
he's like yeah you know like uh i have
multiple girlfriends i'm the only guy
they've uh you know i've never never
been lied to by
i sometimes look and i go i feel sorry
for you a little bit i feel sorry for
you and
i even if i joke to my friends i'm like
i have the perfect
amount of success
i almost i'm worried to have too much
more too many temptations too easy you
know when when things become we live in
an age where our devices are too
replaceable you know
uh no iphone comes out suddenly the old
ones obviously see you later whatever it
is
i never want that to be the same with
people
and that's where i feel that successful
wealthy men go when they don't
you're falling on the sword to have a
family it's sacrifice
it isn't
always a net positive decision for your
lifestyle there's more meaning to it
than people allude to
and i think when faced with the decision
myself of whether or not i want to do it
i need to say what's the opposite well
what else am i going to do you know
there's
pleasure and happiness again so
different i say to people that everyone
has access to happiness some don't know
it but they do all have access to
happiness not everyone has access to
pleasure and you can live a life of
happiness without pleasure but you
cannot live a life of pleasure without
happiness
and the second you try and fill your
quota of happiness with pleasure you end
up going down dark holes drugs alcohol
sex whatever it is
and people being unaware of that
decision to be proactive in the pleasure
pursuit when really
they're getting woken up by the kids the
taking the kids to school your kid going
through puberty giving you [ __ ] there's
really the happiness under your nose the
whole time that you never really knew
about
so i don't have an anecdote to
unhappiness but i think i have a good
clue on what would bring me a life of
happiness
i've had enough pleasure so far
i'm tired
so what what would you have to do then
in terms of getting getting yourself
into a romantic relationship when i
think about my myself i think well if
i'm gonna be the kind of guy that could
offer what i imagine my wife would want
me to offer i'm probably gonna have to
change this or be a bit more like this i
have to work on this thing that i do
because i'm a bit of a dick there what
are those things for you so this is an
interesting one i think i need to
start
working on myself and being a better
human i don't think i've been a great
human in a lot of my relationships i
think that
i've been selfish and i think that i've
made
bad decisions and then i've blamed the
other person for it because i haven't
i haven't accepted
that it was me being a bad person that
caused that emotion certainly something
i've been reading some books like uh i
read attached and came to terms with my
avoidant relationship style there's
something i really want to work on and
i think that
moving forward
i need to
yes respect my partner but i need to
respect myself and hold myself to higher
standards i think that if i can hold
myself to higher standards i will quite
simply be a better human and i think
that i need to start taking more
responsibility for things because
so many things in life you can
work your way out of and you can you
know
change and develop and build to it and
i need to put that attitude into
relationships so it's not saying it's
easy
but i'm saying it's it needs to be done
so i think that
i have work to be done i think i just
need to communicate that with whoever
i'm with and just say look
if you look at my books i'm great you
look at my academy i'm great live talks
give me sell out the o2 i'll be great
relationships i've got some [ __ ] work
i'm coming with baggage so you know as
long as someone is open and accepting of
that i think that's the first hurdle i
don't think i've ever sat that down
before i think that when i've arrived at
relationships before i'm like well babe
i'm going to be a lot more interested
than what else she's [ __ ] dated
and that has to go
you say you need to be a better human
give me just a
couple of specifics when you say a
better human because that's quite broad
you get quite a lot of options
being well known having an instagram
inbox you have a lot of temptations you
have
there are there are quite frankly women
that i've i've even met on nights out
and i say hey i've got a girlfriend and
they go i don't care
and they say i'm not going to tell her
and
having that
means that you have to raise the level
of who you are you are no longer just a
32 year old warm-blooded male you have
you know
options in front of you these are more
difficult to say no to because
one of the biggest issues i believe men
have with the dating scene is they need
to win a woman's trust when you are well
known they already have the trust
it's danger lurking at the door
it's opportunities it's
you know
so many of these things to rise to that
challenge
is no easy feat and that's why i believe
so many men have fallen it's a
self-destructive pattern as well because
so many men
have amazing families beautiful wives
and great kids
and they just lost that ability to be a
strong man for one hour
and it's gone
it's a tough ask it's a tough challenge
but then everything has been so far none
of this has particularly been easy it's
been enjoyable but it's not been easy so
that's something that
i'm gonna have to work on but i want to
revel in that because my mom and dad are
still together that's you know something
that
i'm grateful for and it's something that
they still argue they still have bickers
you know my dad made my mom cry the
other day saying she's going to shop in
too much because of the covered rates
and i was like
they're it's crazy to see
my dad can't even watch the gory part of
a film but [ __ ] he's a strong human he
stayed in the same business for 50 years
he stayed in the same relationship 50
years i think it's about time that i
like took inspiration from them on
things outside of business
lastly as you're writing a book about
confidence confidence i let you say that
first just in case i was like the cat of
the bag but you're writing a book about
confidence why are you doing that
and what have you learned from starting
that process it's something that really
i wouldn't come at it from a place of
hey my name is james i know everything
about confidence my sweat patches
wouldn't say that but
it's something so
inquisitive it's a tool in which i've
used and you know when i was writing the
first chapter i called it a superpower
then i deleted that because super bowls
are unobtainable this is obtainable and
i've come to realize during the writing
i'm learning a lot as well i'm like is
confidence genetics i go into
heritability and then i go into
you know what different types of
confidence are there how does it affect
us
you had mel robbins on recently so i
started listening to her book five four
three two one it's like five four three
two one i'm still [ __ ] my pants
asking this girl for a [ __ ] number
like then i i like to get into these
systems i go that might work for someone
but that doesn't work for me and
during this process i'm not releasing it
until january next year i'm going on
these journeys i'm asking myself these
questions i'm very happy to go to
external
experts in that field there's quite a
bit of nonsense out there i feel and
similar to the world of fitness i'm not
the most fit guy but i took the field
and i provided clarity i'm not the
expert in life design but i went out i
created a book on clarity i wouldn't
want to come into a place of confidence
go hey i'm the most confident person on
the planet because so many of us that
are very confident in certain realms
have gaping holes in our confidence
every one of us
you and i
right you're doing uh o2 arena 16 000
people in there do your thing we'd be
like let's go
you're in sorrow house on a friday night
all right girls give me that let's go
ask your phone number no no no
i'm too scared so
if we can help people identify their
gaping holes give them understanding for
it
is it merely a perception
of our external
reality
is it something that's nature is it
nurture
it's
i wish i had more for you right now but
i'm still learning and
again someone goes why should i buy a
book in confidence okay it took me a
year and a half
it's 12 quid don't [ __ ] buy it then
so
yeah it's one of those things it's very
exciting project for me and
even now i enjoy talking to people i
admire about it because they'll say
something and i'll be like i can't wait
to research that and go down the rabbit
hole and have 20 browsers open on my
laptop it it's an exciting progress
process that i really enjoy
well listen uh james you know we've got
one more thing to do which is a
tradition of the divers ceo which you
might have seen before if you've watched
a podcast before which is the previous
guest asks the next guest a question and
they never know who they're writing it
for and also i never know what the
question is until i read it so
what is your definition of luck
when preparation meets opportunity
i disregard luck when people talk about
it people say i got lucky i said [ __ ]
you
i'm like no you didn't and i
i hate the way people connect people's
dots i hate it
for yourself someone goes high right age
right time right time right educate [ __ ]
you
you know i hate it no one's lucky
and i think that
although there are certain privileges
people can have please never
underestimate someone's work because
connecting the dots is a primitive thing
that we do
and
you know the better people can suppress
the notion that they're lucky they can
be fortunate in some respects
but this luck i don't
let's not undo people's work
i completely agree and i also think that
um to add to that when you start to
believe in this religion of luck what
you're actually doing is disempowering
yourself you're handing over the reins
of your life to this force outside of
your control and you're just sitting
there aimlessly hoping that it falls in
your favor and i so when peop when i
post things sometimes i i'd like to wind
people up on my stories and the things
i'll post are like
honestly the easiest way to wind people
up is just to talk about personal
responsibility
okay
you weren't to blame for what happened
but you are now responsible one of my
guests who was it um
mark manson he said okay someone leaves
a baby on your doorstep
not your fault but it is immediately
your responsibility
and and people just and no god outside
is that people just [ __ ] hate the
idea of like taking responsibility for
your life
um but i think that
any other choice
pointing at luck pointing at privilege
too much despairing that the tory
government are in power so that's why
you're poor is a way to hand to to
choose your puppet master as this
invisible force that gets to call the
shots
thank you so much
you were nervous you said to to come and
do this today you know what i actually
about two three hours ago i stood up and
i said
i'm not nervous i really care about this
podcast yeah because
for me
when i got the invitation it got me
excited the opportunity to talk i know
this platform i know i think i have a
good idea of where this podcast is going
as well yeah and for me to have an
opportunity to not be instagram james
meant a lot to me so
it's more of a fact that this was
important to me i wasn't scared for it
yeah yeah
that's amazing and you know i
i personally just took a screenshot of
you after seeing you say something
online and sent it to my team i think
about two weeks ago and said and i never
do this right what happened the podcast
typically works is the team will come up
with people that they know that i would
like and they'll send them to me to
approve or not but it worked the
opposite way around with you i saw
something you said i thought this guy's
truthful he's honest he has he's smart
really smart
probably way smarter than i think people
give you credit for because
honestly this is one of my favorite
conversations ever thank you and it's
but not because you have a you know just
just because you have a great story it's
because you have the wisdom to point at
the lessons you've learned and you have
the humility also to point at them with
impartiality um so i i was like can you
reach out to this dude and please ask
him if he wants to come here and that
doesn't always happen um so again it's
for me when you say you're this was
important for you and i saw you did an
instagram post saying i'm going on a
podcast that's really you know for me
that is like the most it's the greatest
thing that we hear i just want to say
thank you because honestly it's one of
my favorite conversations ever on this
podcast and i mean that thanks i don't
have to say that i don't gasp people up
if i don't have to i just oh thank you
goodbye but no i genuinely mean that
it's really really really amazing
conversation and
i i also now understand why you've been
so successful
so thank you for your time thank you for
blessing us with your wisdom and uh yeah
gonna keep watching you grow and grow
cheers
[Music]